you look gorgeous
somebody's getting married
ben affleck and jennifer lopez are
officially married we're super happy
yeah nearly one month after their
intimate vegas wedding the couple's
families and a-list pals were on hand as
they say i do once again
let's go inside benefit 2.0 big day i'm
ready i'm excited about it the
celebration at ben's estate in riceboro
georgia made a big splash with a star
aesthetic guest list
jayla won't just leave me alone uh that
was great
yeah
j-lo made sure ben's bestie matt damon
and his wife luciana rsvp'd we've also
learned jennifer's twins emmy and max as
well as ben's three children violet
seraphina and samuel were all in
attendance
another old friend of ben's director
kevin smith shared this pic from the big
day
and the matching attire here is no
coincidence
and he said it's a green diamond
my favorite color green's her favorite
color sure but the wedding's dress code
may have called for guests to wear all
white a source tells us most of the
women wore white dresses while a
majority of the men opted for white
suits
the day kicked off with guests meeting
at perry lane hotel later boarding
shuttles supplied by old savannah tours
plus an insider says guests at the hotel
were met with goodie bags that had the
letters jb inscribed on them we do our
best the ceremony was officiated by life
coach jay shetty a close friend of
j.lo's love
is choosing to be patient when your
partner is finding their way
last year she was featured on jay's hit
podcast on purpose
why don't they teach kids from very
young to love themselves i'm i'm with
you on that that's that you should start
that school jen and ben's wedding guests
were treated with an extravagant
fireworks show to close out the
celebration oh wow
and on sunday the weekend capped off
with a barbecue at ben's mansion
we're trying to get some can you see if
we can get in the papers because i'm
trying to get more publicity when it
comes to the wedding venue it seems like
a full circle moment for the newlyweds
ben bought the house when they were
dating in 2003. i live down south of
savannah i think it's beautiful i went
and shot a movie down there forces of
nature with sandra bullock he's gonna
give us a ride
all the way to georgia and i just
totally fell in love with it and the
people were wonderful and you know i
live down this long dirt road and people
are very respectful of people's privacy
and stuff down there yeah and this house
is massive located on georgia's hampton
island the waterfront property is
completely private spanning 87 acres
with a 6 000 square foot house and a
helipad and shed for seaplane arrival
feeling so lucky it's not often you get
a
second chance at true love
we feel very lucky
i love you
i love you too
and the affleck's plan on making even
more memories at the home
a source tells us quote ben and jen
redid the house to be their personal
taste
it's no question that ben and jen love
the location
[Applause]
[Music]
you